(rock music)
- Hello, and welcome
to Rate My Drafts,
the show where my guests
decide whether my drafts
are a perfect joke,
(dinging)
or un salvageable.
(buzzing)
I wish I had more sage wisdom.
In fact, I wish I knew
anything about herbs.
- Yes.
- Or how to live a good life.
- I like it, it's great.
(dinging)
- Alright.
- Yes,
big buck buck, Forrest Gump.
(buzzing)
- Okay, so do you get the joke?
- It just didn't make me laugh.
- I think it's a joke.
(dinging)
- They say you hurt
the ones you love,
but I didn't love the
kids I hit with my car
and they got hurt so bad.
(dinging)
(laughing)
- Everyone loves
violence, right?
- Alright.
- Violence is funny to me.
(dinging)
- Violence is funny.
- Especially violence
towards, nevermind.
- Violence towards
children is funny,
according to the Young Turks. '
- I mean, let me tell ya, I
think it's funny, personally.
- Okay, great.
- But I feel like,
- Just...
- Politically correctness.
- Got a tight grip.
- I need to, I gotta
stick with red.
- And we're not
getting under that bus.
- Here's a fun fact,
did you know Microsoft
is also how Bill Gates
describes his penis?
- Are you micropenis
shaming Bill Gates?
- I'm not body shaming anyone.
It's just a joke.
- No, I mean that's,
I mean, everyone
heard it, right?
- I love that one.
(dinging)
- Hey, alright.
(laughing)
- I just got a lot of love
for my micropenis brothers.
- Yo, what's up, man?
(laughing)
Nothing wrong with that,
just gotta be good at head.
- Rubbing snake.
- Let's check out Windows 95.
(laughing)
It's his testes.
- Fun to do, run up to someone
about to enter their home
and yell, hey hold that door!
- Your face is what
makes it funny.
(laughing)
You got a funny face.
- I don't think so.
I think it's a--
- I'll say
it's a perfect joke.
(dinging)
- Well, it's a good
face and a perfect joke.
- It would be better
if you didn't read 'em,
which is how it works.
Which is great.
(buzzing)
(dinging)
See, it's better (laughs).
- My sleeve just came off.
- What?
(laughing)
Oh my God.
- I laughed so hard
I came out of my,
(grunting)
I hulked out of my outfit.
(laughing)
That was hilarious.
- People who are smart.
- Excuse me, sorry.
- And are the best.
- Thank you.
I'm doing the, oh, okay.
Wow, outfit change (gasps).
How's it look?
- Where's my leather jacket?
Thank you.
- And it matches yours.
(laughing)
This is a really good set,
can I make sure to
get y'all's number?
- My number is 508801 (beeping).
- Is it actually?
- Please text me compliments.
This one you gotta
do a little voice.
- Oh.
- People always talkin'
'bout jumpin' jacks,
but no one ever talkin'
'bout push up Phils.
(buzzing)
Alright.
I'd say the closets
I ever was to my mom
was when I was in her pussy.
- Oh, God, that
was, sorry (laughs).
- Perfect joke.
(dinging)
- Oh, okay.
(buzzing)
- That is, that is...
- Oh, okay.
Okay.
- That's true.
(dinging)
- A perfect joke.
It's true.
- It's true.
- It's the same for
all of us, I think.
- Oh yeah.
- You turned me.
- This was, I wrote
this last week.
- But it's really when you're--
- When I had sex with my mom.
- Oh, gosh.
(buzzing)
- Oh.
I didn't take it like that.
- And so, if there
was one that you might
retweet, if I were to post it.
- Throw them in the sky,
and then I would
pick any of them.
- [Jordan] Okay.
- Yep, I wish I had some more
sage wisdom, it's so good.
Can I tweet this one?
- Can you tweet it?
- Yeah.
I mean, I know
you've written it.
I can give you some credit.
- I wrote it.
I spent...
- It's not like, you know,
- Are you gonna credit me?
- Hollywood where like I change,
erase the name and
say I wrote Magnum PI.
- How are you gonna do it?
Are you gonna tweet it
and say, jordypizza,
which is my URL?
- What would you, jordypizza?
- Yeah, do that.
You can do that right now.
- [Both] A very good joke.
- [Flula] Nice one, Jordy!
- Should we hit the paddles?
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- I got.
(dinging)
- Micropenis boys.
- Micropenis boys, wait, one,
- [Both] Two, three.
Micropenis boys.
- Can we actually cut that?
I don't want that to...